[Musique]
oui la réalité plus belle mais où est la
réalité c'était aérotrain qui se déplace
sur un matelas d'air à quelques
centimètres du sol
est ce la réalité d'aujourd'hui ou celle
de demain débarrassé de tout contact
avec la terre il est capable de se
déplacer à 600 km à l'est de relier
paris à lyon en 45 minutes
restera-t-il un jouet une maquette ou le
prendrons nous demain comme nous prenons
aujourd'hui le métro ou l'autobus et
pourquoi ne pas imaginer que cette
technique de déplacement sur des
coussins d'air puisse être utilisé pour
d'autres moyens de transport pour les
voitures par exemple voici ce qu'en dit
son constructeur
monsieur bertin
j'ai entendu dire parfois que il était
inutile de construire des autoroutes que
toute façon dans 10 ou 15 ans tous les
véhicules seraient à coussin d'air et
qu'il suffirait d'avoir des espaces plan
pour pour qu'ils se déplacent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez enfin pour
le moment c'est une notion je ne vous ai
pas la qualifier trop sévèrement
enfin elle est sûrement complètement
erroné dans dans l'est dans l'optique de
ce qu'on peut faire avec les coussins
d'air actuellement je pense que là où
les coussins d'air ont des très gros
chance comme je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure c'est pour l'aérotrain par
exemple qui est après tout un transport
public qui n'est pas un transport
individuel également le premier débouché
des machines libre des aéroglisseurs
lives
nous le voyons sur la manche par exemple
ou pour la corse
encore une fois c'est un transport
public collectif des machines individuel
utilisable sur terre à la demande
des particuliers en toutes circonstances
nous voyons pas comment elle pourrait
fonctionner est un excès machine à côté
de leur très grande qualité ont un gros
défaut c'est qu'elles n'ont pas de
pouvoir directionnel on appelle pouvoir
directionnel la faculté d'un flux même à
grande vitesse rapidement sur la
position qu'elle occupe un moment donné
par rapport au sol c'est ce qui permet
un automobiliste d'éviter le celui qui
vient en face quelquefois 10 centimètres
près parce que en quelques centièmes de
seconde
il a pu gagner les 10 ou 20 cm qu'il lui
fallait pour l'éviter on n'imagine pas
le nombre d'accidents qui sont évités
par cette faculté
un aéroglisseur ne l'a pas par
conséquent nous ne voyons pas comme une
circulation de nombreuses aéroglisseur
sur une piste où une voie de du genre
autoroute vous faites pour eux pour les
produits nous ne voyons vraiment pas
[Musique]